what's up guys so if you've ever
followed me on Instagram or watched any
of my vlogs on my other channel you know
that I love Legos so recently me and my
sister put together its the r2d2 set I
think it has over 2000 pieces probably
took us both about six hours to complete
jenna helped me for the first part of it
and then as you'll see in the video of
the third day I just was like I'm
finishing this it was like 2 a.m. I was
so tired I realized I had missed a few
pieces so I screwed up some things enjoy
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you guys like the video I will tell
you there was a piece that I could not
find so right here it was this long six
stud piece that was missing I don't know
where it is I still don't know where it
is so I kind of just removed the one
from here and put it up here to kind of
get it all to work also you may notice
there is a missing piece right here I
was so far into building this that by
the time I realized that I had messed up
there was no going back so what I plan
on doing is fouling off the studs and
just slipping it in here and hopefully
that will work its bottom also comes out
here we go
I just have to flip this little switch
on the back and that will allow me to
put his little leg back in so I'm gonna
go set him down and like give you guys a
nice little overview of him
you